ask me anything except about what's
happening in this footage captured from
my neighbor's doorbell security camera
[Music]
okay so anything you guys want to ask me
about anything in my career my life
Simpsons episodes or Senate live my
childhood I am an open book yes you have
a question sir yeah I had a good
question but honestly I forgot what it
was because now I'm just wondering what
the hell was going on in that video okay
as the title of this segment clearly
states I cannot answer any questions
about that footage from my neighbor's
security camera especially while it's an
ongoing investigation
someone else anybody else yes you hey
Conan
I love the new half-hour format and I've
got a question okay sure what's your
which question was that you wearing that
rabbit mask okay you're asking about
that security camera footage and I'm not
allowed to discuss it however I will say
this
throw a rock anywhere in Los Angeles
you're bound to hit a dozen middle-aged
guys that are six foot four 190 pounds
and very pale okay they're everywhere
all right so you if they weren't a mask
you don't know who they are
next question yeah how do you come up
with all your ideas great like where do
I come up with the idea for like the
Simpsons monorail episode okay where the
idea for doing travel shows that kind of
thing where'd you come up with the idea
to walk around ass out nothing but a
bunny mask and handcuffs
I'm could have been more clear about the
rules of this question and answer I
cannot and I will not discuss anything
to do with the footage from my
neighbor's doorbell security camera for
my alleged affiliation with the religion
axiom okay axiom isn't that the weird
sex coat that worships forest animals it
is not a sex cult not a sex cult from
what I hear it's this great it's this
great new religion that's hoping a lot
of people who are going through some
weird stuff in their lives and I'm not
even at liberty to discuss any of that
so just next question please just next
question hey Conan huge fan um is it
true that you got a tattoo as a tribute
to your wife yes finally a fun question
in fact that is true I have a very small
ladybug tattoo on my shoulder because my
pet name for my wife is ladybug Billy
can we break up a little picture of my
little ladybug tattoo there it is right
there it's a little hard to see pretty a
pretty cute little ladybug tattoo there
huh
wait is that a cattle brand scar on your
back and does that say oxy I'm like that
crazy sex cop it is not a sex cult next
question are you in some kind of batshit
crazy animal worshipping sex slavery
pulse we are your fans we have a right
to know Andy that disguise it's not
fooling anyone it's ridiculous hi it's
me Andy yeah we know look no one gives a
wet turd about your comedy influences or
your childhood we want to know about the
crazy sex cult right guys you picture
booth off of me I will not be silent
let's wait to thank you brother Eli
thank you sister Rebecca
long live oxy yes well that's all the
time we have for
[Music]
about what's happening in this footage
captured from my latest doorbell
security camera
[Music]